the return to Sundance with Kevin Smith
it's been 22 years every time I come in
but this has been an insanely emotional
trip this this week because I went to
the director brunch which I've never
gone to four times I've had a movie here
and I've never gone to the director
bunch I tried in 94 me my producer Scott
Mosier drove up to Sundance the actual
little town up there to go to the
director brunch couldn't find it and
then we like forget let's leave so I've
never gotten to the director brunch 22
years later like I was like you know
what I'm gonna go because I wanted this
it sounds so shitty but I wanted to get
a selfie with Redford so I was like I
know it's gonna be there forever so I go
to the director brunch and it's every
year they have it for all the filmmakers
and Redford gets up and gives the all
like we are indie speech which I've
never heard before I heard from other
people like all gives a wonderful speech
so I went I showed up just I saw a lot
of people that I've known over the years
and the festival like Cooper and Trevor
drops people look for the flick in the
fest and then Redford gets up to speak
so I'm leaning in the back of room
against the wall like total Silent Bob
style just watching the stuff and you
know everybody's all enthusiastic
because he's the Guru instead and he
proceeds to drop a speech man which I'm
sure he's done a zillion times in his
life but he starts talking about he's
like when I was kid I love these weird
movies but there's no home for him and
stuff and I always said if I could get a
little success I would do something
about that I would want to shine a light
on he's like and then in 1980 we started
thinking about how to take the u.s. Film
Festival turn into Sundance and stuff
and then the rest became history and
he's like and he said this thing I start
bawling I was crying in the back of a
room and I saw like Lena Dunham was
sitting in the front she was like why is
he crying like I was bald because the
dude talked about a sense of communities
like there was this time where we all
felt like we needed to build a community
for these people who made these movies
and you know I was one sentence shy of
being like the freaks in the end the you
know the people that I was a part yeah
people were like oh my god I would love
to make a movie but I'm not part of that
world or something I don't feel normal
like everybody else I feel this real
pulse of the Arts
the dude was literally talking about and
again he's probably giving that speech a
thousand times but I just started crying
because I was like the students telling
the secret origin of my life like I know
my life story work at the convenience
store come up here at the movie and then
everything changed none of that happens
unless that actor one day is like I
should get back you said this thing
about like you know he's like a big into
the Native America
communities like you know they believe
whatever you take out you got to put
back you got to replace so he was
talking about that stuff and I'm sitting
there hearing the secret origin of my
career unless he does that I don't do
anything I'm still working at a
convenience store and I realized like oh
my God my mom patronized this dude's
movies
when I was a kid she's like I love
Robert Redford who like and because she
patronize that dude's movies like years
later that dude was like hey I got
enough time and money to create a film
festival yeah and then the years later I
get to go the film festival in 22 years
later I come back but with her I didn't
have a kid lesson come back with Lily
Rose Harley just in the rest of the cast
in another convenience store movie this
one's set in Canada so it shows growth
as a filmmaker no more just Jersey now
okay I didn't and now honestly like I'm
glad I didn't because I would have been
like oh crap but I've heard him speak
about the movies I've made and I've
never been in the room with them yeah
and it was intense man because I this is
probably the one person in this world
who I've never met who has a greatest
impact on my life like huge so I did
wanna at the end I wanted to go hug him
but he went right
you